Hello again. I really appreciate you sticking with me through this course and hope you're
learning a lot from it. In this lesson, we'll be exploring level management as well as
checking a peek at the Stage Monitor and Level Snapshots tool we have at hand.
Alright, first and foremost, what is a level? We've been interacting with some since the
beginning of this course but we never actually sat down and accurately defined them. A level
also commonly referred to as a map is a self-contained 3D environment or scene that serves as the
stage for our content. Now, the concept of level management in this case is a hot topic
for linear and legacy production, but not really for game development. In games, you
would rather use something called world partition instead, which lets you basically slice a
large map into smaller ones and use level streaming to load or unload them as the player
moves across the scene. Depending on the complexity of your environment, you could handle using
a single level only, especially if you're flying solo, but as soon as you start working
with a team on a real-time production, level management becomes an essential part of your
pipeline. That's because it allows different artists to collaborate on a scene at the same
time and that's without interfering with each other. You basically chop the elements
composing your environment into different tasks assigned to different artists and each
one of these tasks, like lighting, props, vegetation, could be allocated to a separate
map and all of these maps together would generate the final scene.
Level management could also improve your viewport performance, especially when working on a
cinematic or animation production, because camera or animation artists could isolate
the areas of an environment where the animation could be taking place and save resources to
increase the frame rate on their viewport to play the work in progress animations in
real time. So, level management is really important and learning how to work with it
will make you a true real-time team player. Alright, the main tool behind level management
lies in the Levels tab. And there are a few ways of adding a level to your Levels tab,
so let's review them directly in the engine. Alright, we want to navigate to Window and
then down here you can find Levels. That's not to be confused with the Layers panel,
even though the naming is quite similar and they're next to each other, so I get that
it can be a little bit confusing. But compared to the Levels tab, the Layers panel gives
you the ability to control the visibility of groups of actors in your scene, so it doesn't
handle the visibility of your maps entirely, but simply the visibility of the assets that
are already in that map. But today we want to take care of the maps individually, so let's
click on Levels instead. So you will see up here that there is the Persistent Level. The Persistent
Level is the father of all the sub-levels or the levels that are within it. The Persistent
Level in this case is the Assembly Small Level. Now the Text in bold means that this specific
level is active. The Active Level is the one where the changes will be applied to if any
changes are applied to the scene. And if you double click on any of the levels within the
Levels tab, you will make that level active. This asterisk icon right next to the text means
that there are unapplied changes to the map. So if, for example, we make the Geo Level active,
and then we add a cube in it, you will see that the change would be applied to the Geo Level,
and here there would be an asterisk because there are unsaved changes. So if you Control
Shift-Test, we would apply your changes to all maps and save all. And then if we toggle the visibility
on and off of the Geo Level, you will see that the cube would be in it. Now there is this NDC
level out here, which is basically just a tool to send red letters to the LED volumes. Okay,
let's delete this cube and Control Shift-Test again. Now if you wanted to, you could add an
existing level to your Levels tab. You can do that either by selecting the level you want to add
in the Content Browser and then drag and dropping it into the Levels tab. Or I'm just going to
delete this. We can just click on these Levels down arrow and then add existing. And you can
select that you want to add as sub-level to our Persistent one. Now if the level you're trying to
create doesn't exist yet and should contain assets that are currently present in your scene, then you
can easily select them in the Viewport and then go to Levels, create new with selected actors,
choose a name and then save. I'm not going to do it right now because I don't want to mess around
with my levels. Also, if you wanted to, you have the option to merge multiple levels. So you can
just select them in the Levels tab and then go under Levels and Merge. And this will create a new
level with all these sub-levels merged into one. To keep things organized, you can also create
new folders and name them as you want, like sub-levels or whatever you need. Then you can just drag and
drop the levels you want into them. Now if I click this icon up here, I will be able to
summon the level details. And I can choose the level I want to spec in either from up here or just
by selecting it in the Level tab. And something really cool that you can do here is adding some
offset to the entire level. And if you click on this Viewport Edit button here, you will be able
to reposition it directly in the Viewport. Now these changes will be applied to the entire map.
Right now the cube sub-level just contains a cube, but if we had multiple assets, those would be moved
together with it. Alright, we can close this down. So once your desired maps have been added to the
Level tab and everything is properly organized, you can choose whether you'd like that scene to be
always loaded or loaded via Blueprint. You can access this option by right-clicking on any sub-level
and then changing the streaming method. Now this can be a little confusing because when working
within the Editor Viewport, it doesn't matter whether a level is always loaded or loaded via
Blueprint. As long as its visibility is turned on in the Levels tab, then it will be displayed in the
Editor Board as we work in our level. The difference though stands in how these levels will be streamed
at runtime, meaning that if we were to either play or I'm just going to click on this hamburger or
simulate, and I'm just going to click on simulate, our map, the always loaded maps will be displayed,
but the ones that are added via Blueprints will be disabled unless correctly added via Blueprints.
So as you can see here, our cube streaming method is via Blueprint. The Geometry Level is also
loaded via Blueprint and the NDC is also loaded via Blueprint. If we change the Geo Level to be
always loaded and then try to simulate again, you will see that just the cube and the NDC
Level would be disabled because we have no Blueprints actually loading these levels.
So unless you plan on setting up a Blueprint to load the levels at runtime, it's a good idea to
just set the streaming method of your maps to always loaded. All right, let's go back to the
slides and check out the Stage Monitor plugin. Now, full disclosure, the Stage Monitor doesn't have
anything to do with level management. They serve completely different purposes,
so I just wanted to point that out. But since this course is designed to introduce you to the
fundamentals of world building for virtual production, we felt it would be important to
mention it nonetheless. The Stage Monitor is a tool that lets you review and manage multiple
computers running Unreal Engine at the same time. This is typically used in a virtual production
setup where you often have many computers working together, one displaying the background of your
scene on an LED wall, another editing the scene itself, another for Niagara FX, and so on. The
Stage Monitor acts basically like a control center and gives you an overview of what all
these computers are doing. To get started with the Stage Monitor, there are three plugins you
need to enable. So let's jump into the Engine and check them out. I'm gonna stop simulating,
and then I'm gonna go under Edit, plugins, and then search for Stage Monitor and make sure that
the Stage Monitor plugin is turned on. After that, I will search for virtual production
utilities and make sure that this plugin is turned on. And then there is a third one that is
optional, which is called Switchboard, that in our case is gonna be turned off because we don't
need it. But just so you know, the Switchboard is basically a remote control for all your
Unreal Engine instances across different computers. Okay, we can close this down. And once all of the
required plugins are enabled and the Engine has been restarted, we can go to Windows,
Virtual Production, and Stage Monitor. Now in this class, unfortunately, we won't be exploring much
of the Stage Monitor as we don't have any machines synchronized to it and neither any
end display preconfigured. But there is an entire course dedicated to it on our educational platform,
so I'd encourage you to check it out. All right, let's go back to the slides and check out the
Level Snapshots tool. So, Level Snapshots allow you to basically take a picture of your scene
setup so that you can return to it anytime you like. The Snapshots save the exact position and
settings of everything in your World Outliner. You can even choose whether you want to restore
an entire scene back to how it was when you took the snapshot or just bring back some specific parts.
This tool is very useful for virtual production because it lets you revert your changes on the fly
if your Creative Director or DP changes their mind about the look of the scene. It's important to
note though that while Level Snapshots work flawlessly with dynamic lighting or Lumen,
if you're trying to use them with light mess or big lighting, restoring light changes might be a
little tricky because the lighting would need to be rebaked at each instance, so it wouldn't be a
very smooth change. All right, let's jump into the Engine and see how the Level Snapshots work.
We can close the Stage Monitor and then we want to go to Edit, Plugins, and then search for Level
Snapshots. So, the Level Snapshots plugin needs to be enabled in order for us to use them.
After you've restarted the editor and the plugin is enabled, you will find this low icon up here
and right next to it these three dots and if we click on them, we will be able to open the Level
Snapshots Editor. So, before we apply any changes to our map, let's just take a snapshot of its
current stage and we can name it Original Assembly Small, which is the name of the map,
and then we want to save it under Levels and I'm just going to add a slash back up to add a new
folder. I don't want it to be saved into any other subfolder, so I'm going to delete this
and the name of the default Level Snapshot is fine. So, let's click on Create Level Snapshots.
Okay, now if we navigate to Backup, we can find the Level Snapshot Asset. All right,
let's apply some changes to this map. So, I'm going to go into my Outliner. I'm going to click on
this cube up here and then I'm just going to move it around. I could also change the material on it
and assign a different one like red, a red material, and I could also just select the directional light
and rotate it around by making it more like the sun is almost setting. Okay, so once I'm done with
my changes, I can either click on this take snapshot button or I can also just click on the one up
here in my toolbar and I'm going to call it Dawn Assembly Small. Again, we want to save it to Levels
slash backup. We want to delete any further subfolders and then create our Level Snapshot.
Okay, perfect. So, now if our DPO director wanted to revert the changes to their original stage,
we could just select our original snapshot by double clicking on it and then restore the Level
Snapshot and it would even tell us the actors that would be modified compared to the current settings.
So, let's click on restore Level Snapshot and you will see that all the changes would be applied.
And if they change the menu again and wanted the Dawn, you could just double click on it
and that'll restore the Level Snapshot. Now, these changes were applied to the World Outliner
and it didn't matter whether the assets we changed were in any of these sub levels. In fact, the cube
asset is part of our cube sub level, but we still changed it and reverted it back. That's because
it is part of our World Outliner. But there are certain changes that our Level Snapshots want
to detect. For example, if we were to add a new level to our Levels tab and then take a snapshot,
the Level Snapshot would just detect the changes in the World Outliner, not in the Levels tab.
So, you wouldn't understand these meshes are part of a separate sub level. It would add them,
but to the persistent level. So, you gotta be careful with that. If you apply any changes to your
level management structure, those won't matter in the Level Snapshots. I hope this gave you an
idea of using Level Snapshots in the editor and how you can use it to your advantage in a virtual
production setting. Now, let's go back to the slides to conclude this lesson. Alright, that was
it for this class. And at this link, you can find other extensive documentation and resources to
further expand your knowledge in managing multiple levels, the stage monitor, and the Level Snapshot
tool. In the next lesson, we will be getting an overview of working with materials in Unreal Engine.
Have fun building some stunning environments and I'll see you soon. Bye.